[Música]
Venezuela se prepara para las votaciones
primarias en la que los partidos
opositores buscan elegir a un único
candidato que sea el rival de Nicolás
maduro en las presidenciales de 2024 y
el tiempo para buscar a los posibles
aspirantes comenzará el 5 de junio e irá
hasta el 23 del mismo mes la votación
será el 22 de octubre de este año pero
no será una decisión nada fácil la
oposición venezolana ha estado
fragmentada especialmente desde que se
disolvió el autoproclamado gobierno
interino de Juan guaidó a finales de
2022 y ni siquiera los líderes
opositores tienen un consenso alrededor
de si son necesarias o no estas
primarias seguirán sin un personaje
representativo que pueda hacerle frente
al chavismo en Venezuela o lograrán
poner sus diferencias a un lado otra
duda sobre la mesa es si el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro respetará las fechas de
las elecciones presidenciales en 2024
para hablar de esto en el debate tenemos
a dos invitados en nuestros estudios en
Bogotá
xiaomi las Heras leiza Hola periodista e
investigador adscrito al observatorio de
Venezuela de la Universidad del Rosario
de Colombia y también presidente de la
asociación diálogo ciudadano Colombo
venezolano también está con nosotros
Alejandro Martínez él es politólogo y ex
embajador del gobierno interino de Juan
guaidó y desde Caracas nos acompaña
Indira urbaneja analista y estratega
política fundadora Además del movimiento
chavismo bolivariano a todos ellos
bienvenidos y a ustedes nuestra
audiencia les recuerdo que también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en todas
nuestras redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram nos encuentran como
arroba franz24 raya al piso es pueden
comentar con la etiqueta numeral el
debate f24 y a mí me encuentran como
arroba maríacle Aguirre no olviden
además que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí quiero darle la bienvenida a
nuestros tres invitados del día y quiero
comenzar por Show me Gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros vamos a hablar primero
de Cuál es el panorama que tenemos de
los candidatos para estas primarias
sobre todo en las que Enrique capriles y
María Corina Machado van punteando al
igual que Benjamín racedo Sí bueno
efectivamente primero que quisiera decir
que esta es una oportunidad de ejercicio
democrático importante no en democracia
las diferencias o las competencias se
dirimen votando y la oposición
venezolana por lo menos el sector
mayoritario de la oposición venezolana
pues ha decidido dirimir esto en unas
elecciones primarias Creo que este es un
punto bien importante y en este sentido
pues las diferentes opciones políticas
tuyas mencionadas algunas de las
principales pues ya han colocado sus
precandidatos que de alguna manera pues
ya están en en campaña o en precampaña
no una vez que estarán en campaña
oficial una vez que sus candidaturas
pues sean ya
entre Pues en competencia formal no y
bueno en la fecha que tú has dicho
yo diría que ese podría ser un resumen
de Cuál es la la situación efectivamente
hay un sector de la oposición también
que todavía no no ha decidido si entra o
no entra pero pareciera que este no es
el sector por lo menos hasta el momento
mayoritario en la en la oposición y mira
y le quiero preguntar a usted cuál el
panorama que usted tiene sobre estas
elecciones y los candidatos que aunque
todavía hay tiempo para elegirlos cada
vez hay más caras bueno en primer lugar
debemos recordar que esto no es un
proceso donde participa toda la
oposición todo lo contrario es un sector
de la oposición quien Busca un candidato
un candidato dentro de su mismo espectro
es decir no vamos a ver a una oposición
unida porque fuera de las primarias hay
otra posición que no se siente incluida
que también va a buscar su candidato
empecemos por allí para entender y que
quienes nos escuchan Lamentablemente
entiendan que no va la posición es muy
difícil que haya presentar una
candidatura unitaria qué es lo que se
siente en Venezuela hoy más del 60 por
ciento de los venezolanos según un
estudio muy reciente y de una
encuestadora muy confiable no sabe que
se van a realizar las primarias el 22 de
octubre es decir pareciera que el
proceso primario se sigue quedando en
las redes sociales y se sigue quedando
en el tema de nosotros los analistas
político No es cierto que la toda la
población venezolana está enterada de
que este proceso va a ser y esto lo
señalo como una de las fallas del
proceso precisamente o sea yo creo que
aparte de las de los digamos El dilema
interno de presentar una candidatura
única o no de ver cómo se van a lograr
unificar o no cómo van a llevar un
proceso primario sin dejar heridas Hay
también una desconexión con la base
votante quien hoy todavía no se siente
identificado con el proceso y que
todavía ni siquiera sabe cuál es la
fecha cómo lo van a hacer Cuáles son las
condiciones Porque todavía dentro del
proceso ni siquiera se sabe si se va a
ir con el cne o no se va a ir con el cne
o sea todavía el proceso primario sigue
mostrándose como algo muy incipiente
como que si todavía no está todo
definido y el tiempo está corriendo es
decir estamos muy cerca del 22 de
octubre para uno podría ser un tiempo
muy largo pero todos sabemos en temas
electorales que es un tiempo muy corto
lamentablemente yo creo que este no de
haber sido el mecanismo que la posición
tenía que seleccionar para buscar un
candidato candidato unitaria creo he
sido muy crítica del proceso porque no
estamos en Suiza no estamos en Noruega
estamos en Venezuela el proceso de
primaria los va a desgastar los va a
llevar a una confrontación que va a
dejar heridas irreconciliables y frente
a un panorama donde más División y donde
más fragmentación haya del sector
opositor El chavismo gana con mucha más
comodidad le quiero entonces preguntar a
Alejandro por varios de los puntos que
está planteando Indira y Comencemos por
esta falta de apoyo unánime a las
primarias dentro de la oposición quiénes
son esas facciones que se están alejando
Porque por ejemplo Leopoldo López de
voluntad popular está diciendo que desde
acción democrática y el partido un nuevo
tiempo no apoyan tanto las primarias y
que por ejemplo figuras como Enrique
capriles no estarían apoyando las tan
directamente a pesar de que es uno de
los candidatos bueno obviamente no hay
un apoyo unánime este Porque si hubieron
absolutamente unánime no habría
necesidad de primaria este hay una
situación muy difícil en Venezuela
porque la primarias no es que es un
mecanismo que que está este reducido a
las redes sociales es que es un
mecanismo que se en el cual se busca
generar un proceso democrático en un
país en el cual no hay prensa en el cual
los medios han sido este
controlados hay la autocensura medios
cerrados hasta el edificio del nacional
el periódico más emblemático del país se
lo quitó pero fraudulentamente un
tribunal por orden de diosdado cabello
uno de los capos de la de La dictadura
entonces bueno Esto es una carrera de
obstáculo en la cual se busca generar
con muy pocos recursos un acuerdo
político que justamente permita que los
defensores de la Democracia la gente que
ya que representa a quienes están
cansados de la falta de libertad en
representación de todos esos venezolanos
que salen huyendo del país algunos hasta
descalzos atraviesan la frontera este
porque es un país que le está negando a
sus ciudadanos las condiciones más
básicas entonces en representación de
toda esa gente que está comprenderá que
en un país donde el sueldo mínimo son
cinco seis ocho dólares eso es la
mayoría del país abrumadora entonces en
representación de esos venezolanos hay
que hacer este proceso que por cierto ya
se hizo una vez en 2012 y fue un proceso
sumamente exitoso el que dio la
candidatura de Enrique capriles radosky
de modo que este es un proceso que
enfrenta básicamente los obstáculos que
pone el régimen que dice no sabemos
Cuándo va a ser la fecha esa fecha está
establecida en la constitución pero eso
ya lo han violentado entonces bueno este
la la digamos el el modo socarrón como
Nicolás Maduro señala bueno no sabemos
Cuándo va a ser la elección este el otro
dice que no sabe si se pueden hacer sin
el cne bueno este a Eso nos enfrentamos
los demócratas y lo vamos a seguir
haciendo y yo agregaría a este panorama
que nos pinta Indira y Alejandro Que es
una oportunidad que tiene la oposición
para movilizarse así efectivamente hay
una situación muy difícil por un lado
por la represión que ejerce el gobierno
y por otro lado porque Bueno hay
fragmentación efectivamente en la
oposición pero un proceso este tipo es
una gran oportunidad para movilizarse y
para incentivar y motivar también al al
electorado a participar eso creo que no
debemos olvidarlo tampoco Y entonces
para usted Sería un una oportunidad de
democracia para legitimar esta
democracia como es lo que ha defendido
la oposición o para usted puede ser un
mecanismo incorrecto que va a debilitar
y a agotar la fuerza de la oposición
como lo está diciendo Indira No yo no
creo que necesariamente tenga por
afectar yo creo que bien llevado el
proceso puede más bien motivar Y ser un
factor digamos de de irrupción de la
oposición que ha pasado momentos muy
malos están en el pasado en el en años
anteriores la oposición ha tenido
momentos de letargo muy importantes y ha
logrado sobreponerse el último caso
importante fue el de las elecciones del
2015 que las venció digamos abiertamente
No desde entonces el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro ha ido cerrando mucho más el
sistema los grifos los medios de
comunicación y hoy en día la oposición
actúa con muchas más dificultades pero a
mí para mí es muy importante demostrar
el mundo que esta oposición está optando
por medios democráticos está usando una
herramienta democrática como es las
primarias y yo sé que hay riesgos
indudablemente riesgos puede ser que se
pueda generar una lucha intestina a raíz
de un proceso de este tipo eso siempre
está en el en sobre la mesa pero también
puede producirse al revés se puede
producir un proceso que que genere un
candidato que genere entusiasmo y que
consiste el apoyo de las demás opciones
ustedes mencionan dos puntos que son muy
importantes tratarlos aquí en el debate
el primero de ellos es la discusión de
si el Consejo Nacional electoral que es
el órgano oficial de todos los comicios
en Venezuela debería o no participar en
estas primarias que por ahora están
siendo lideradas por la Comisión
Nacional para la elección primaria que
es un órgano independiente que se forma
sobre todo con académicos Pero antes de
pasar a discutir ese punto quiero hablar
del segundo tema que ustedes ponen sobre
la mesa y fueron las declaraciones del
presidente Nicolás Maduro porque él el
13 de abril de 2023 en medio de la
conmemoración del regreso al poder de
Chávez después del breve golpe de estado
él dice literalmente y cito no sabemos
si las elecciones presidenciales serán
este año o el guárdenme ese secreto esto
en un poco para poner al contexto en
nuestra audiencia las elecciones
presidenciales serían en 2024 y la
oposición está diciendo que el gobierno
quiere mover estas elecciones para antes
incluso de las primarias y que así los
partidos opositores no puedan nombrar a
una única figura Algo similar pasó en
2018 cuando el gobierno adelantó las
elecciones que iban a hacer en diciembre
de ese año y finalmente las hicieron en
mayo y diría Le quiero preguntar
entonces Cómo interpretar estas palabras
del presidente maduro
fíjate quienes llevamos el pulso
político y sabemos que esto es parte de
una constante digamos en el discurso
sobre todo oficialista en el discurso
del gobierno Porque además yo lo veo
siempre como una especie de concha de
mango una especie de trampa que el
gobierno siempre le pone la narrativa y
la oposición de alguna forma cae el
chavismo está buscando legitimidad es
más necesita legitimidad es más todos
los sectores tanto posición como
chavismo necesita que las elecciones
presidenciales venideras sean un proceso
legítimo para que el país empiece a
abandonar su crisis política y empieza a
reconectar con el concierto
internacional por qué te explico esto
porque el chavismo no va a tomar el
riesgo de adelantar una fecha de forma
arbitraria hacerlo de forma unilateral y
lo he dicho muchísimas veces el chavismo
y el gobierno no lo van a hacer
exceptuando que exista un acuerdo con
sectores y factores de la oposición
Entonces yo creo que es un poco parte de
esta na que para mí ya es costumbre el
gobierno no es primera vez que lo hace
siempre lo hace un poco para dar de qué
hablar con los medios quizás a veces
también son globos de ensayos bueno
lanzo esto para ver cómo reacciona la
opinión pública nacional como reacciona
la opinión pública internacional yo
estoy convencida que el chavismo va a
jugar en la fecha correcta porque está
buscando legitimidad está buscando
abandonar la crisis política y
cualquiera adelanto unilateral de fecha
que esté fuera de lo que es el tiempo de
la Constitución lo que manda la ley le
más bien lo aleja de esa legitimidad que
está buscando yo creo que esto es lo que
llamamos show de micrófonos y yo no me
detendría tanto en eso y más bien me
preocuparía si yo desde los sectores de
oposición me preocuparía más bien porque
este proceso termine de tomar forma
realmente el proceso de primaria No
termina hoy de convencer a los
venezolanos por mucho que se quiera
apostar Yo estoy de acuerdo con Johnny
sí es un proceso Es una herramienta
democrática sería el estado ideal pero
tenemos que recordar que no estamos en
el escenario del 2012 en el escenario
del 2015 el gobierno interino lo que se
llamó gobierno interino que fue el
autoproclamación de Juan guaidó como
presidente ha dejado profundas
divisiones también dentro de la posición
porque recordemos que es precisamente
ese sector El que está participando en
las primarias es un sector que se ha
acusado entre ellos de corrupción todo
entonces ahí ya hay unas heridas
preestablecidas que se van a profundizar
con la primaria Por eso es que yo he
dicho que la primaria Es una herramienta
especial Sí es democrática también pero
no creo que es el timing para yo hubiese
escogido otra forma realmente para
buscar un candidato candidato unitaria y
antes de pasar aquí le quiero contra
preguntar por qué dice usted que estas
primarias no convencen
no convencen porque si algo está
buscando el electorado opositor en
Venezuela es
unidad Pero además no nada más unidad un
proyecto unitario que va más allá de una
persona o de un líder o de una
candidatura esa base opositora Sigue
esperando madurez política que esto es
importante que quienes nos escuchan
también lo vean Porque es muy fácil
siempre decir que el gobierno el
gobierno el gobierno Sí el gobierno
juega su juego pero también hay que
decirle al mundo que la oposición sea
entrampado en sus narrativas anti votos
antielectoral la oposición ese sector de
oposición que hoy Clama primarias y que
hoy está organizando primarias llamó a
la atención montón de veces y son hoy
responsables incluso de la pérdida de
credibilidad que hay en el sistema
electoral Entonces cómo vuelven después
que han dicho que votar no es el camino
que no se vota en dictadura que no se
puede votar mientras que Nicolás Maduro
está en el poder Hoy entonces reclaman
primarias Hoy entonces reclaman y por
eso se entrampan Entonces eso no es lo
que no termina convencer Porque todavía
ni siquiera le has ido a explicar a tu
base por qué ahora si hay que votar Sí
usted Menciona un punto y es el gobierno
necesita legitimidad y de hecho tanto en
las negociaciones que han adelantado el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y los
opositores de la plataforma unitaria han
reiterado que se necesitan elecciones
libres y de hecho ese punto también fue
uno de los grandes acuerdos de la
conferencia internacional sobre el
proceso político de Venezuela que lideró
Colombia del otro lado Indira nos
plantea que estas primarias no convencen
y que la oposición ha llamado a la
abstención y ahora llama a las
elecciones que responder ante eso
Alejandro bueno en una democracia un
presidente no puede estar poniendo
concha de mango si el presidente está
para respetar la Constitución para
garantizar el derecho los derechos
políticos el derecho al voto es uno de
ellos solamente para para que toda la
institucionalidad democrática le
ciudadano las garantías para que ejerce
para llamar a la participación no para
andar diciendo que no sabe que le
guarden el secreto que quizá la que
quizá modifica la Constitución la viola
eso no puede ser Entonces ese ese esa es
la realidad por eso que yo digo que esto
es una carrera de obstáculo porque el el
chavismo ASUME que este hay que yo como
yo necesito legitimidad Yo puedo ser
cualquier cosa puedo violar las normas
Por qué Por qué se llamó la atención en
un determinado momento porque no hubo
elecciones competitivas porque no hubo
hubo unas elecciones fraudulentas porque
inhabilitó a los candidatos es decir
sacó de circulación a todos los
candidatos que le parecieron
inconvenientes los que tenían
posibilidad de ganar
secuestró los partidos políticos en
Venezuela los principales partidos
políticos están hoy intervenidos Cómo
será la la crisis
brutal que ha generado el chavismo que
hoy está a punto y si usted revisa hoy
la prensa encuentra al partido comunista
de Venezuela
declarando su secretario general que
están a punto de quitarle el partido Es
decir de intervenir el partido para
apropiárselo como lo ha hecho
compartidos incluso decir el partido
comunista hasta hace nada apoyaba al
chavismo pero lo ha hecho con los
partidos de oposición ahora se lo está
haciendo incluso al partido comunista de
lo que se trata no es de llamados a
legitimidad este es que ellos pueden
hacer su propia narrativa no la
narrativa de la Democracia es el respeto
de los derechos es la norma es la
institucionalidad Esa es la narrativa de
la Democracia no hay otra no puede ser
que yo altere las normas cuando me
conviene que que yo busque este sacar de
circulación a mis adversarios eso no es
democrático eso es lo que lleva esta
situación en la cual el pueblo
venezolano está sumido en la pobreza más
absoluta y de hecho en las elecciones
regionales y locales de noviembre de
2021 la visión de observación electoral
de la Unión Europea analizó estos
comicios y una de las recomendaciones
fue dejar participar a los políticos que
estaban inhabilitados por la contraloría
en estas primarias esos políticos podrán
participar
en Venezuela ha habido inhabilitaciones
a candidatos por por no haber declarado
al impuesto un lo que se llama un sexta
ticket Pues un ticket de alimentación
que se da como complemento a un a un
funcionario esa ha sido razón para
inhabilitar gente bueno en otros casos
ni siquiera ha habido este ningún tipo
de de justificación es Sencillamente
además el procedimiento por supuesto
absolutamente ilegal cuando se tiene el
control de el Consejo Nacional electoral
del tribunal supremo este cuando se
tiene el control de la institucionalidad
de la fiscalía
usted juicios que pierda el gobierno
usted no ha visto que el fiscal general
de la nación opere en defensa de los
derechos de los ciudadanos este cuando
cuando
se trata de un caso en el cual el
gobierno está comprometido ese claro y
esto seguramente es una discusión de
nunca acabar y es la discusión que está
dándose en Venezuela sin embargo
nosotros por cuestión de tiempo debemos
avanzar y le quiero preguntar a chomin
por tres puntos que han causado
diferencia en estas primarias el primero
es la participación o no del Consejo
Nacional electoral la segunda es si debe
haber o no un voto manual que es lo que
por ejemplo defiende líderes opositores
como María Corina Machado Y si deben o
no votar los venezolanos que están en
otros países y que han migrado de
Venezuela qué piensa usted de estos tres
puntos y cuáles son las mayores
dificultades en toda esta discusión
bueno efectivamente hay un sector de la
oposición que tiene una gran
desconfianza al voto digamos
automatizado que se hace que se hace en
Venezuela y ha planteado que la
oposición digamos o la plataforma
unitaria que está organizando esta
primaria No no participe digamos
conjuntamente con el Consejo Nacional
electoral pero a mi juicio mucho más
importante que esa discusión que
indudablemente uno entiende que genera
genera preocupación en mucha gente
porque en el pasado digamos cuando el
gobierno ha sabido quiénes van a votar
digamos por opciones opositoras
como fue el caso del referéndum que se
hizo en alguna oportunidad contra Chávez
luego Se generó pues una lista donde se
se actuó en contra de esta gente sobre
todo cuando eran empleados públicos
tenían gente que tenía contacto con el
estado sin embargo para mí Mucho más
importante que esto que es un riesgo que
creo que hay que correr es poder lograr
que por lo menos dos millones de jóvenes
venezolanos que no están inscritos en el
registro electoral se escribir que se
abran los plazos suficientes para que
estos jóvenes se puedan inscribir y
alrededor de más de cuatro millones de
venezolanos que están en el exterior que
tampoco en este momento podrían votar Y
qué hipotéticamente tendrían la
posibilidad de hacerlo si creo que la
discusión la presión que habría que
hacer sobre el gobierno para que todo
está masa de gente tan grande estamos
hablando de más de seis millones de
personas millones de personas puedan
votar creo que sería un factor mucho más
importante porque
creo que mucha esta gente indudablemente
Podría tener opciones favorables a
opciones digamos opositoras y y esto
podría contrarrestar mucho los miedos
que pueda haber de que el gobierno pueda
saber quién ha participado o no en un
proceso por ejemplo de primarias y muy
breve A qué se debe Ese temor de saber
quién votó en las primarias bueno porque
en el pasado y eso fue lo que sucedió en
el referéndum que se realizó en
Venezuela ya hace casi ya dos décadas
casi el Se generó una lista que fue la
la llamada lista tacón y el gobierno lo
utilizó para actuar en contra de persona
actuar como votando las de sus trabajos
presionando a los empleadores para que
las votaran de sus trabajos no dándoles
por ejemplo los programas sociales que
podía tener el gobierno ese tipo de
acciones que han sido una constante en
el chavismo y ahorita en el en el
madurez Indira Ahora quiero ir con usted
Qué responder frente a estas preguntas
de si abrir o no la O si permitir o no
la intervención del Consejo Nacional
electoral y de hacer voto manual o
automatizado Y cómo serían unas
primarias completamente de
autogestionadas y Qué responder a lo que
dice chomin Perdón sobre la
participación de los jóvenes y de los
venezolanos que están fuera del país
Sí en primer lugar yo creo que la
oposición recordemos que este sector de
oposición necesita
reconectar con su base necesita
explicarle a su base porque ahora sí hay
que votar Aunque antes no se votaba Y
eso pasa también por recuperar la
confianza en el poder electoral que la
gente sienta que votar es confiable mira
Si no si la gente sigue escuchando el
mismo tema de siempre que van a hacer
trampas que las máquinas son
manipulables todo entonces como tú vas a
lograr una votación masiva No hay forma
de que la oposición desaloje al chavismo
del poder si no logra una votación
masiva y para eso Entonces cuál sería el
mensaje el mensaje más positivo es vamos
a hacer nuestras primarias con el cne y
vamos a tratar incluso de identificar
alguna falla que nos pueda servir para
el proceso electoral cómo tú le explicas
a la gente que no vas a utilizar al cne
para hacer tus primarias y que si la vas
a utilizar después para la elección del
2024 para la elección presidencial eso
es contradictorio hay mecanismo y se ha
hablado Por ejemplo yo entiendo incluso
la denuncia y de aclaro que yo no estoy
a favor de que se judicialicen y que se
vayan en contra de nadie por su
motivación política o por su preferencia
política pero ya se ha hablado incluso
de un mecanismo donde la capta huella
que es una maquinita que registra quien
votó y le del votante ya se ha hablado
incluso de la posibilidad de que esta
información de que esta Data sea borrada
para impedir que el gobierno tenga
acceso a ella y se vaya
instrumentalizar de forma negativa hacia
la gente entonces mecanismos hay yo creo
que la oposición debe de alejarse de la
narrativa que está en contra del cne
porque más que vencer a maduro la
posición tiene que buscar vencer las
tensión es más todos los venezolanos que
queremos un proceso confiable un proceso
legítimo electoral tenemos que más bien
impulsar la votación es la votación
masiva y está demostrado que no pueden
manipular las máquinas si hay una
votación masiva Pero además ese mismo
cne a quien hoy tú acusas de que es un
cne que no tiene confianza es el mismo
cne con el que ganó Manuel Rosales que
es un gobernador opositor y se le
entregó su gobernación es las mismas
máquinas y el mismo cne con la que la
oposición ganó en el 2015 de manera
abrumadora y aplastante a las elecciones
par Entonces es un error que sigan en
esto y ya para cerrar con el tema de que
bueno qué respondemos vamos con CNN
vamos con CNN se puede instrumentalizar
de forma negativa No mira yo creo que lo
ideal es que se vaya con el cne y que se
tomen todas las garantías técnicas para
el caso ahora con respecto al voto en el
exterior es muy difícil porque
recordemos que nuestra diáspora no está
legalizada en todos los países por
ejemplo cómo van a votar o pueden votar
ahorita en la primaria las personas que
están en Estados Unidos pero no hay
consulado en Estados Unidos es decir
esas personas en las elecciones
presidenciales no van a poder votar Yo
estoy de acuerdo que tienen que votar
los niños los jóvenes los ancianos
Perdón los niños no votan pero los
ancianos los jóvenes todo alrededor del
mundo en Venezuela Pero técnicamente va
a ser imposible y no tiene sentido de
que voten hoy en la primaria y mañana no
vayan a poder votar en la elección
presidencial no tiene ningún sentido
Alejandro Cuál es su postura sobre si
acercarse o no al cne y Cómo hacer para
permitir o no el voto de quienes están
en el extranjero Bueno yo creo que la la
desconfianza que ha sembrado
el el cne es muy peligrosa porque Busca
la la digamos la pérdida del valor del
voto y
en cada votación se han hecho tantas
formas de fraude que el ciudadano se
siente realmente escéptico qué es lo que
yo creo fíjate un delincuente puede ser
delincuente porque el cne ha sido
llevado adelante de una manera
delincuencial ahora todos los
delincuentes no utilizan todos los
mismos delitos no decir hay delincuentes
que se especializan en una cosa y en
otra el cne especializado en presionar
para para el voto en sacar de
circulación a los enemigos políticos
pero yo creo que el principal enemigo de
Nicolás maduro en términos electorales
son las máquinas porque las máquinas no
lo que usted marca es lo que sale es
decir el fraude está en sacar de de los
medios a los a los candidatos opositores
en la inhabilitaciones en poner a un a
un funcionario público que lleve en un
autobús a todos los que dependen de él y
separe el el individuo al lado a ver
cómo votan esos son todas las formas de
fraude que están recogidas por la este
misión de observación electoral de la
Unión Europea incluso hasta por el
informe del centro Carter ya anterior
entonces
esa discusión que la siembra también el
régimen la posición tiene que superar
esa discusión ahí yo coincido con con
nuestra amiga tiene que superar esa
discusión porque
concentrarse en temas como el del
efectivamente el voto en el exterior el
voto en el exterior es perfectamente
posible y ha sido desde hace mucho
tiempo en el 2012 había aproximadamente
100.000 personas in en el exterior
porque bueno en esa época habría dos
tres millones fuera solamente Pero el
régimen ha impedido que la gente se
inscriba hay un software para eso que
estaba en las embajadas eso tiene diez
años que ni siquiera pagan la licencia
del Software Entonces esto no es un
problema de es que hay una una decisión
política de quitarle a los venezolanos
su posibilidad de votar eso es
perfectamente posible organizarlo en el
exterior Ya el cne en ocasiones ha
violado ese derecho ha habido elecciones
en las cuales eso está establecido en la
en la en la ley en la Constitución eso
no es una decisión de que de que bueno
yo sí soy amplio vamos a permitir que
voten los venezolanos No eso es la ley
tan violandola las normas muy brevemente
Le quiero preguntar a otro tema y es
rápidamente Usted cree que hay unas
condiciones internacionales diferentes
esta vez que posibiliten y faciliten las
elecciones primarias de la oposición en
Venezuela y segundo las presidenciales y
lo digo concretamente uno por la
posibilidad de que Estados Unidos
levante las sanciones que ha sido uno de
los pedidos reiterados y dos por
gobiernos de izquierda en América Latina
vuelve Lula a Brasil el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro en Colombia que facilita
esta Cumbre hay un panorama
internacional diferente esta vez que
favorezca unas elecciones en Venezuela
Sí indudablemente hay un panorama
internacional diferente y creo que hay
un interés internacional en que hay una
salida democrática a la crisis política
y no solamente política la crisis
política económica y social que vive que
vive el país Así que efectivamente si
hay un interés en el caso de Colombia El
presidente Gustavo Petro se ha implicado
incluso personalmente y ha tratado de
buscar algunas vías en sus encuentros
con maduro incluso realizó un encuentro
aquí en Bogotá
internacional también para impulsar la
reanudación de las negociaciones en
México
porque el el los representantes del
gobierno de maduro se levantaron no eso
no está claro si eso se va a reanudar o
no pero sí creo que hay un interés
internacional en en que la que haya una
salida democrática así el tema de la
guerra en Ucrania creo que incide de
manera importante y sí creo que hay
muchos Estados Unidos Europa quieren que
que en Venezuela las cosas encuentren
una solución de allá que vaya a haber
una solución pues eso todavía no lo
sabemos bueno Y ahora por cuestiones de
tiempo debo hacer ya la ronda de
conclusiones y quiero comenzar al
contrario Alejandro Cuál es su
conclusión sobre estas primarias de la
oposición Cómo entenderlas bueno son un
reto para la para los opositores este
estamos justamente en el en los
comienzos de la campaña no es nada fácil
no hay no hay no hay recursos
abundantes Precisamente hay hay también
diferencia entre los opositores tiene
que haberlas para eso se está yendo la
primaria y bueno lo que queda es esperar
que los venezolanos participen que
participen que que sepan este tener
Clara la su decisión las razones por las
cuales va a votar que tengan claro Cuál
es la la Cuál es la la grave situación
que atraviesa Venezuela y la necesidad
de que todos los demócratas lo que
quieren que superemos esta situación que
ha llevado ocho millones de personas
afuera que ha generado una crisis
humanitaria
espantosa de las más graves de la
historia del país esto Solo es
comparable con Las Guerras de
Independencia entonces que lo que
queremos superar esto nos unamos tras
una candidatura Puede que no sea la que
cada uno de nosotros individualmente
quiera la que la mayoría decida Esa es
la que hay que apoyar Indira y su
conclusión sobre estas primarias
Bueno yo reitero no apoyo el proceso
porque yo hubiese preferido que la
oposición hubiese sido un cónclave así
como se va cuando se va a elegir un papa
que se encierran en la Capilla Sixtina
yo creo que eso le hubiese ahorrado
costos confrontación y hubiese sido una
demostración incluso de mi culpa y de
aquello cuando tú dices Bueno hemos
reconocido nuestros errores ahora vamos
a deponer nuestros egos y vamos no a
elegir un candidato a una candidata sino
la persona que tenga los credenciales
para darle la confrontación y la batalla
al chavismo porque te voy a decir algo
No es simplemente elegir a un candidato
a una candidata es elegir a una persona
que tenga cualidades específicas Como
por ejemplo la posibilidad de ganar que
por supuesto es importante Pero además
la posibilidad de tener la garantía de
que el chavismo le va a entregar el
poder es decir tiene que ser una persona
que genere confianza en el chavismo que
genere confianza en las fuerzas armadas
que genere confianza en todos los
sectores del chavismo y lo tercero una
persona que pueda garantizar la
gobernabilidad por eso es que
lamentablemente yo creo que ese
candidato no va a poder escogerse en
unas primarias Igual yo les deseo suerte
yo no voy a voy a no voy a hacer nada
para implosionar las primarias pero yo
creo desde mi punto de vista que la
oposición se equivocó al escoger este
método y muy brevemente su conclusión
bueno el consenso era una posibilidad
que era un proceso pero si no hay
consenso la vida democrática es
confrontarse democráticamente Entonces
no hubo consenso hay que ir a unas
elecciones primarias para escoger
entonces creo que esa es una vía
legítima y creo que pues hay que hay que
recorrerla con los riesgos que tiene
indudablemente pero hay que recorrerla y
creo que es una oportunidad también como
bien lo dije al principio porque puede
ayudar a movilizar a la a la oposición y
al pueblo venezolano también para que
vaya a votar las
jardines y Indira urbaneja Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
el debate por acompañarnos y a ustedes
gracias por sintonizarnos y les digo
gracias En nombre de nuestro equipo
técnico la producción estuvo a cargo de
Luis Fernando Montes y la producción de
los invitados con Tania Herrera ustedes
sigan conectados con nosotros en Flash
[Música]